[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 choisir
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
del sol une des pièces maîtresses de
lucinda childs sera jouée ce soir au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
spectacle entre rêve et réalité que vous
découvrirez en images la 25e édition de
la fête de la science débute ce week end
dans toute la france pour l'occasion
d'observatoire de verser 50 ans ouvre
ses portes nous recevrons annabelle
doazit organisatrice de l'événement pour
nous en parler enfin le tricot a envahi
le centre-ville de maurepas une forme de
street art qui porte un nom le yang wang
bing une initiative pour redonner de la
couleur à nouveau
pour les sportifs ce samedi à plaisir
aura lieu la course run and bike après
le succès de l'an passé la ville
organise une deuxième édition au coeur
du parc du château le concept coureurs
et vététistes forme un duo
complémentaire et doivent alterner
course à pied et vélo le but franchir la
ligne d'arrivée obligatoirement ensemble
plusieurs villes ont déjà organisé cette
course comme versailles ou encore
maurepas et selon l'organisation tout le
monde de participer on écoute l'agglo
l'adjoint au maire par don délégué au
sport au micro de michael et demi
d'euros il ya une difficulté notamment
d'un parc du château il ya une bonne
cote après il doit y avoir
difficultés dans le
dans la forêt de bois d'arcy et
et puis c'est tout mais c'était c'est
assez roulant et surtout en cette saison
il ya eu quelques pluies mais là le
terrain et quand même ils viennent
duriez il se prête très bien à ce genre
de compétition c'est ouvert à tout le
monde un amateur
amateurs et amateurs éclairés je dirais
il n'y a pas de professionnels un an ce
type de course puisqu'il n'est pas doté
de prix importants mais effectivement il
faut quand même ça entraîné un petit peu
parce que ça va quand même assez vite ce
soir le ballet de l'opéra de lyon
interprétera dance au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est l'une des pièces maîtresses de
lucinda childs grandes figures de la
danse américaine un spectacle presque
cinématographique aux musiques onirique
nous sommes allés suivre la répétition
avant la première jeudi 6 octobre les
images de david charpentier
des mouvements envoûtant presque
hypnotique la chorégraphe américaine
lucinda childs en a fait sa marque de
fabrique au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le ballet de l'opéra de lyon
interprétera sa pièce maîtresse dance un
chef-d'oeuvre de la danse contemporaine
est là c'est mouvement elle que
généralement quelle qu'elle aime bien
utiliser des soutenu des temps lever
enfin voilà beaucoup de changements de
direction de diagonale de ligne de
départ de personnes à des endroits
différents mais doivent le un timing
tout à fait ensemble la bande-son
derrière et pas forcément très rythmée
mais alors il ya un tel travail que les
départs 10 danseurs sont
impeccablement en même temps créée en
1979 dance est devenu une pièce
intemporelle la musique lancinante signé
philip glass ensorcelle le spectateur un
dispositif filmique laisse entrevoir les
reflets des danseurs sur la scène aucun
faux pas n'est tolérée le ballet est
réglé au millimètre
avec mignot est conçu retrouver sur
scène
on n'est pas tout à fait au même temps
donc on a beaucoup travaillé sur ça sur
scène et c'est vrai que ça change
franchement je nourris beaucoup
simplement exceptionnel dans cette pièce
que j'appréciais beaucoup que j'ai tout
manque un grand l'histoire derrière le
ballet de l'opéra de lyon est la seule
compagnie à avoir refait le film avec
ses danseurs dance est constitué de
trois parties de 20 minutes sans
entracte une heure de mouvements de
sauts et de grâce féerique un voyage
entre rêve et réalité
[Musique]
la 25e édition de la fête de la science
débute ce week-end dans toute la france
à rendez-vous jusqu'au 16 octobre pour
rencontrer et échanger avec des
chercheurs ingénieurs et techniciens à
cette occasion l'observatoire de
versailles-saint-quentin ouvrira ses
portes au public annabelle doazit nous a
rejoint en plateau elle s'est occupée
d'organiser l'événement a lobé s cube
bonjour annabelle bonjour alors allo psq
la fête de la science commence le
mercredi 12 et se finit dimanche 16
octobre et les premiers jours sont
consacrés aux scolaires qui pourront se
découvrir dans vos locaux lors du
mercredi 12 au vendredi nous allons
recevoir aussi bien des petits des
écoles élémentaires de cp au cm2 que des
collégiens ou des lycéens ils vont
pouvoir découvrir différents
laboratoires de l'observatoire le latmos
le ca recule encore le lsc eu des
ateliers des manipulations sur
l'arctique sur les gaz à effet de serre
le jardin partagé une plateforme
d'intégration et de test enfin la
plainte de choses différentes et ludique
sur tout et du coup un petit move
représenter peut-être loupé est ce que
c'est une structure de recherche
scientifique et ou participer à des
programmes spatiaux vous étiez notamment
sur la mission rosetta mission qui s'est
terminée la semaine dernière tout à fait
alors l'observatoire effectivement à
trois labos
trois labos il y a le ls c'est eux qui
s'occupent des problèmes qui concernent
le climat le ses arcs qui travaille
notamment pour l'article sur
l'adaptation des populations aux
changements climatiques et puis le
latmos qui effectivement un observatoire
qui est un laboratoire d'observation
spatiale est effectivement la mission
rosetta s'est arrêté vendredi dernier le
30 septembre donc la sonde est arrivé
sur la comète souris est donc ce qui a
mis fin à la mission ce sont des moments
qui sont assez sûr des moments pleins
d'émotion pour les chercheurs et les
scientifiques et pour nous aussi
d'ailleurs mais il ya plein de
rebondissements si je puis dire par
exemple là nous avons la mission exomars
qui est en route là pour mars qui est
une grande grande mission il ya un
instrument qui s'appelle micro ars qui
est à bord de cette mission et qui a été
conçu au latmos par nos chercheurs qui
est un instrument français et voilà ce
sont des moments qui sont très
importants qui permettent si je peux
dire de rebondir un petit peu la
démission qui s'arrête et d'autres qui
sont qui comme champ aux toiles et donc
du coup la fête de la science sera pas
réservée qu'aux scolaires vous m'aviez
le 15 octobre une journée entièrement on
exactement de 14h à 17h30 nous
accueillons les 6-12 donc nous prenons
en charge les enfants pendant toute la
demi journée et nous laissons les
parents c'est vraiment une prise en
charge des enfants et c'est vraiment
adapté aux petits avec plein de petites
choses qui permettent d mais la science
et de passer vraiment des informations
de manière ludique donc du coup
l'objectif c'est vraiment ça c'est de
faire découvrir un petit peu l'univers
de la science autrement que ce qu'on
peut voir les choses avec des cas un peu
plus concret absolument c'est un petit
peu c'est ludique c'est rigolo mais en
passe vraiment d'informations on essaye
de susciter des vocations un petit peu
parfois et puis on essaie de les
sensibiliser aux problématiques de
l'observatoire bien sûr à noter
également pour le grand public plusieurs
manifestations auront lieu toute la
semaine avec notamment la visite du
latmos et le laboratoire de recherche d
atmosphère terrestre et planétaire mais
également des projections des
projections tout à fait nous avons cette
année exceptionnellement fait un
partenariat pariscience qui est un grand
estivale de documentaires parisien qui
va démarrer là dans quelques jours et
nous avons fait un partenariat donc on a
des films qui vont passer dans le cadre
de ce festival à guyancourt qui sont
bien évidemment gratuit et ouvert au
public et vendredi soir à 19 heures le
14 nous avons une projection d'un film
qui s'appelle l'homme qui voulait
changer le monde de mariée de faber donc
voilà je vous invite bien évidemment à
venir c'est entrée libre gratuite et ça
a l'air fort intéressant d'accord on l'a
bien compris ça trois événements se font
sur réservation comme les ateliers pour
les enfants d'autres non bah voilà en
tout cas pour avoir toutes les
informations on vous conseille de vous
rendre sur le site internet de l'ot vs
qu tous les événements sont recensés
merci beaucoup annabelle messi est
revenu sur notre plateau on quitte
maintenant l'univers de la science pour
celui du tricot fini les pulls de grand
mère aujourd'hui le tricot se décline en
stricte en street art pardon si vous
êtes passé du côté de l'hôtel de ville
de mort pas cette semaine vous n'avez
pas pu manquer l'opération de yahoo bing
bing sur la place de la mairie une
soixantaine d'éléments ont été décorés
nous avons suivi des préparatifs avant
le lancement de l'événement ce samedi
tricot et graffitis de passion à
première vue éloignée et pourtant à
maurepas le 8 octobre débute une action
de yarn bombing dans le centre ville une
nouvelle forme de street art qui
consiste à décorer le mobilier urbain
avec les techniques du tricot une
initiative pour redonner de la couleur à
nos rues c'est aussi de donner de la
joie et de la bonne humeur avec des
couleurs et se réapproprier un petit peu
la ville en décorant le mobilier urbain
il ya 50 kg qui on est pétri côté ça
représente à peu près 1000 pelote se
sont que des restes de dons de dons
aussi de bergère de france quatre mois
de travail ont été nécessaires pour
réaliser cet événement une première à
saint quentin en yvelines dans la
boutique de kathleen on s'affaire à
terminer les derniers détails prêté par
le cyclotourisme au club de maurepas ce
vélo a lui aussi le droit d'être
pouponner c'est un adhérent de notre
club qui a prêté gentiment à kathleen
est assez aux personnes qui composent
son atelier un vélo de 50 ans d'âge
que les brodeuses que les tricoteuses
ont habillé de toutes les couleurs dont
le logo de notre club sur les routes on
considère qu'on est on peut être un vrai
acteur du développement du commerce de
proximité en centre ville et c'est
surtout à titre là qu'on a participé au
projet d'un bon bein le vélo sera
installé dans une boulangerie de la
place pendant toute la durée de
l'opération esthétique mais aussi éco
responsable en novembre les ouvrages
seront collectées afin de recycler la
laine en isolation plus de 70 personnes
ont participé à ce tricot graffiti
kathleen espère renouveler l'événement
tous les ans alors à vos aiguilles
les enjeux du climat au coeur d'une
exposition à magny les hameaux jusqu'au
20 novembre la visite se fait sur
réservation auprès de l'estaminet élevé
le vernissage est prévu ce samedi à 19h
il sera suivi d'une projection du film
demain ce documentaire réalisé par cyril
dion et mélanie laurent sortie en 2015
propose une réflexion autour de
solutions écologiques et sociales on
écoute le président de l'amap le panier
des hameaux co concepteur de cette
exposition au micro de david cher
continent a dit il y aura un grand film
le soir le film demain que nous avons
choisi parce qu'il n'est pas trop dans
le catastrophisme et il est très dans le
la documentation précise des enjeux sur
le changement climatique d'autre
parallèlement à ça je ferai quelques
petites conférences
du fait de mon ancienneté comme
chercheur à météo france en sciences du
climat et en qualité de l'air et les
amateurs de musiques extrêmes au rendez
vous au café de la plage de mort pas ce
week end samedi à 20h30 une affiche à
faire saliver les amoureux de death
metal avec les bordelais de gorod le
retour de fathom qui présentera son
nouvel album et des fleisher groupe de
rambouillet en première partie petite
mise en bouche cette soirée avec un
extrait de gorod issu de leur album de
[Musique]
tout est bon
trois rendez vous à noter ce week end si
vous n'êtes pas trop branché métal mais
plutôt musiques du monde djeli moussa
condé sera en concert ce soir à
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux une
soirée pour clore la semaine de la
citoyenneté avec ce chanteur afro pop
aux mélodies entraînantes pour les
passionnés d'histoire une exposition à
ne pas manquer ce week end le fort du
trou d'enfer de marly le roi se consacre
au premier char d'assaut français à
visiter jusqu'à dimanche pour terminer
du cirque à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse
dans le cadre de la semaine bleue un
chapiteau a été installé dans le village
seniors numéro d'équilibriste jonglage
clown deux représentations sont ouvertes
au public demain après midi c'est la fin
de ce set 8 loisirs merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 10 il a
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]